[Music]
first Alex Jones was banned by nearly
all the social media Giants then Twitter
banned Gavin McGinnis then Facebook
blocked Dennis Prager sprager university
videos although it later backtracked and
apologized then patreon and GoFundMe
banned me and making a mistake you may
dislike Jones McGinnis Prager and me but
this isn't over the left is moving
quickly now to silence all dissent and
there is no telling who could be next it
could be you
patreon started the ball rolling when
they deleted the account I had started
to raise funds to renovate an old TV
studio which I had hoped to use for
jihad watch videos patreon gave me no
explanation for banning me other than
saying that MasterCard had demanded that
they do so and the only explanation from
MasterCard was published in Breitbart
news which said a MasterCard
spokesperson responded to a Breitbart
news request for comment with the
following statement as part of our
normal process we share information
about websites that may have illegal
content with the acquirer or merchants
bank that connects them to our network
to accept card payments the acquirer
would then review the site for
compliance with legal requirements and
our standards they would then determine
what action to take in this case the
acquirer advised us that they decided to
terminate acceptance what illegal
content and which website did they mean
patreon or jihad watch all I had at
patreon was a video stating my hopes to
rebuild the studio and a notice about an
upcoming live stream at jihad watch all
we have are news articles almost all
from mainstream news sources with
commentary so to what illegal content
was MasterCard referring it is not yet
illegal in the United States to
criticize Islam and to oppose jihad mass
murder and the Sharia oppression of
women gays and others it is however
illegal to do so under Sharia his
MasterCard operating according to Sharia
blasphemy laws now shortly after that I
started a GoFundMe page to make up for
the loss of patreon but after a few days
GoFundMe canceled my account and
refunded all the donate
Asians GoFundMe sent me this explanation
it seems you're using we pay GoFundMe
service to pay those who receive
donations for one or more of the
activities prohibited by our Terms of
Service we pay is unable to process
payments related to hate violence racial
intolerance terrorism the financial
exploitation of a crime or items or
activities that encourage promote
facilitate or instruct others regarding
the same there was of course no further
explanation now it's very clear what's
going on here the Southern Poverty Law
Center claims that on the heat group
leader and that's that when the SPLC
says jump patreon and MasterCard say how
high
indeed the SPL sees infallibility in
such matters is taken for granted by all
the social media giants as well this
despite the fact that the SPLC made a
massive admission of error in the Maajid
Nawaz case in which they paid a 3.3
million dollar settlement to a Muslim
reformer they accused of being an anti
Muslim extremist which is what they call
me as well the SPL sees far left
political agenda in lumping legitimate
groups in with the likes of the KKK and
neo-nazis in order to discredit and
destroy them is also obvious but
GoFundMe like patreon and MasterCard
allowed me no appeal no discussion no
questioning of the SPL C's Fiat and of
course it isn't just the SPLC
it is now taken for granted by large
segments of the American population and
by innumerable people elsewhere that to
oppose jihad mass murder of innocent
civilians and Sharia oppression of women
gays and others is indeed hate I
remember how flabbergasted I was in 2003
when I was on MSNBC with Keith Olbermann
and Ibrahim Hooper of the Hamas lamed
Council on american-islamic relations
and Hooper called me a hate monger I
thought what it's hate to oppose jihad
terror that's never going to fly but it
has and the outcome will be that more
and more people will be afraid to oppose
jihad terror and Sharia oppression for
fear of incurring these charges and this
discrimination in this libel I'm going
to be doing what I can to challenge
GoFundMe 's uncritically
acceptance of the SPLC s smear of me and
the likely same uncritical acceptance by
MasterCard and patreon but the SPLC has
hundreds of millions of dollars and I
don't and many who don't realize how
vulnerable they are will applaud what is
happening to me because they don't
realize or believe how easily the same
tactics can and will be turned on them
but they will be this is getting very
serious it won't stop with me after my
adventures with patreon and GoFundMe
MasterCard and Visa stopped processing
donations for the David Horowitz Freedom
Center with which I'm affiliated
although they backtracked after an
outcry
despite this small victory it is clear
that the left is moving quickly to
silence all dissenting voices in the
run-up to the 2018 elections the freedom
of speech is the foundation of a free
society and it is rapidly being
destroyed in the United States not only
are Horowitz and me and Jones and Prager
& McGinnis being silenced the pressure
on the credit card companies shows that
the left is now trying to make sure that
we cannot make a living that we will be
quite literally destroyed personally as
well as professionally and there will be
more victims this totalitarian action
needs to be stopped quickly or it will
destroy all who are not doctrinaire
leftists and without any doubt the
United States as a free society as well
I'm Robert Spencer Shulman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the Center for
security policy
[Music]